yes
uh we are expanding the family
uh but you know i have a belief that
when you do things uh you don't just go
you go big
so uh two babies people
two babies are on the way uh those are
ultrasounds what you're seeing over
there
uh
yeah so okay this is gonna be very
confusing to people and i understand
this right like okay wait a minute
you're both dudes you're showing me two
ultrasounds they don't look exactly the
same what's going on there are they
twins are they something else can we
pull those images up again one of them
seems lighter than the other what is
there a coloration problem what's going
on here is this racial i get it there's
a lot of questions related to all of
this so let me just back up a little bit
and tell you about our
sort of fertility
journey so it look when you have two men
or two women you're missing a piece
right you got the sperm
or you got the egg but you don't have a
sperm and an egg right you don't have a
womb you got to figure out some things
here
um and you know by the way i know most
of you guys that are watching this are
now on more conservative side of things
and i i never see any real issue with
conservatives anymore and gay people and
trump was the first you know first time
president to run being you know pro-gay
marriage and i think most people just
kind of want to live and let live and
all that but i know this is like a
little bit weird for some people to hear
right i get it and by the way to me at
some level this is a little bit weird
like i've had to learn a lot of stuff
and go to a lot of doctors and it's and
it's cost a lot of money and it's been a
long
sort of adventure but basically what
you're seeing there one more time with
those
ultrasounds would you uh those are two
different wombs and those are two
different babies
um and i now i now know an awful lot
about
uh birth and i know an awful lot about
zygotes and i know an awful lot about
wombs and days when things start
happening and heartbeat appointments and
all kinds of stuff so basically what we
are doing
is we got one egg donor so you got to
think about this if you need to stop
right now and grab a sharpie and make a
chart uh you could uh so basically we've
got plenty of sperm around here that's
that's one thing right so there's a lot
there's something i'm just saying
there's a lot of sperm we didn't have a
shortage of sperm so we've got sperm so
we had half the battle right we had half
of what we needed but we needed an egg
so there are egg donors that are out
there these are young women who are
willing to donate their eggs women and
women obviously make a lot of eggs
some make a lot of eggs some don't make
eggs but the donors usually are young
and healthy and and if they want to help
people that otherwise can't have
children they can donate their eggs so
you basically
go on all of these websites there are
all these sites and it's sort of like
tinder or whatever app you were dating
on where you're just kind of swiping
through people and you say oh i like the
way she looks or i like this girl had a
great education or
some combination thereof or this one is
actually geographically close i like
this person but they're very far and you
know there are different rates and all
of these things um and our feeling was
that we wanted one egg donor meaning you
get a whole bunch of eggs well hopefully
you get a whole bunch of eggs from the
egg donor and then we would take several
you know we'd split the eggs so let's
say you got i think the first time
around we got like 18 eggs and then you
take the sperm we would split them so
now there's like nine and nine i'm
giving you the rough estimates here um
and you would
then inseminate them
and then you hopefully from that some of
it takes some of it doesn't take but
then in essence you have these embryos
and then you need surrogates so the
surrogate obviously is the woman who
then carries the child so basically what
we've got cooking here is that we have
one
baby that is from
my stuff and one baby that is from
david's stuff but they both will have
the same biological mother and we wanted
them to have that sort of genetic
connection and right now there are two
really fantastic women and you know it's
not an easy thing to be a surrogate this
is not something people really do for
money they do it for a higher purpose
for sure and really two absolutely
amazing women are carrying our babies
right now so we have two babies again
one from each of us biologically but
they will be connected through the egg
the genetic material of the mother
one baby will be born in august
and one baby will be born in october so
they are not going to be twins in a in a
technical sense um but they are they as
a as a life going forward i think
they'll be they'll really be thought of
as twins because you know two months
means means nothing and they'll be in
the same grade and all of that stuff and
we started going through the
the process of how to do this and uh i
can assure you that it is it is not
cheap it is definitely easier if you got
a man and a woman involved uh i don't
think we have to do uh you know sixth
grade biology for you but it's a hundred
percent
easier if you can go that route um you
know what was interesting also
was that throughout the the surrogacy
process
um you know it was during covet
so our
the day we had to deposit the sperm
and you can all figure out what that is
you go to an office
very clinical office and you go into a
special room
they leave you in there for 10 minutes
you do your thing and then they take
that basically they put it on ice and
then they figure out when they're gonna
you know connect it with the egg so to
speak um anyway it was a few days
after they had announced like covid was
going crazy and they were gonna lock us
down and everything else
and uh we lived in l.a at the time we
lived in the valley and our fertility
doctor was in beverly hills so we had to
go over the hill and now you remember
all that when lockdown was happening and
like the roads were like oddly empty but
then suddenly really packed and
everything just felt crazy and it was a
really windy day and basically the
doctor was like look they're telling us
we're going to close down we don't know
when we're going to open up we don't
know if we're going to have nurses here
we don't know you better get us that
sperm asap
and we got in the car we drove as fast
as we could over the hill to beverly
hills uh to donate the sperm as we get
out of the car and i just thought this
is like just such a moment i will always
remember in my life i write about this a
little bit and don't burn this country
actually like i will always remember
this like as we're getting out of the
car lockdown we think like world war iii
or world war z is starting like the
zombie apocalypse is here we've got to
get the sperm to the doctor to save
human society so people will procreate
and we're going to be okay
we're getting out of the car and then my
phone rings and it's donald trump jr and
i'm like man the world's about 10 the
president's son is calling me and then
i'm on the phone with junior and he's
just asking me like you know what do i
think about lockdowns or something like
that he was just checking in i'm on the
phone with junior walking in it was very
windy there's no one on the streets it's
eerie and then we get to the fertility
clinic and standing outside the door of
the fertility clinic is dennis rodman of
all people dennis rodman yeah dennis
rodman former nba player crazy hair
dennis rodman like cross-dressing dennis
rodman who i loved growing up uh and
he's just outside the sperm clinic what
dennis rodman was doing outside of sperm
clinic i don't know he had a skateboard
with him anyway we go up there deposit
the sperm and then you know then because
of covid and lockdowns and everything
else
the process of surrogacy became very
slow one of one thing that you'll
probably find very interesting actually
is that the uh the pool of surrogate so
there's not like zillions and zillions
of surrogates out there right because
you really do and i genuinely mean this
you have to be a very special person
to want to carry someone else's child
right like like you are the vessel to
help
uh create life but it but at the end of
the day it's it's someone else's child
so there's not a ton of surrogates and
over the course of of months where
we were going through covid and
lockdowns and everything else it turned
out that a lot of surrogates i was told
80 percent of surrogates in the market
did not want to get vaccinated for
whatever reason that is whatever
personal reason they had so then there
was a very very small pool
of surrogates obviously we did not want
to force i certainly was not going to do
that force anyone to uh to get
vaccinated or anything like that i don't
want to get too into the weeds on
the science and what we ended up doing
and all that kind of stuff but it just
really made things very complex um as
you may remember um you know there were
a couple miscarriages along the way
which um you know apparently and i'm
sure many of you have heard some version
of this in your own private life uh
there's been an awful lot of
miscarriages in the last two years
doctors don't know exactly what to chalk
that up to is it is it somehow covert
related is it somehow vaccine related
is it somehow stress related of the
world feeling so out of control who
knows uh but long story short uh finally
a couple months back we heard that our
first surrogate was pregnant and a
seriously strong baby like they're
really impressed with this kid the
numbers are off the charts um
and then we were like you know what we
just got to keep moving we got to keep
moving you know i'm 45 years old i'm not
getting any younger i want to be able to
play catch and shoot hoops with this kid
i hurt my hip this last night i don't
know what's going on i was like limping
around this morning like like the clock
is ticking i'm not like uh marisa tomei
in uh
uh what was it what was that movie uh
uh my cousin vinnie you know like her
biological clock is ticking not quite
like that but like you know we had to
move so once once we knew that the the
first surrogate was pregnant we were
just like let's just keep going because
because who knows you know there there
could be other miscarriages there you
know just delays like covid could come
back the doctors may want not want like
there's so many things so many things
um and then we tried again and it worked
so we've got these two
these two babies on the way and uh you
know uh people keep telling me i'm gonna
make a great dad uh we shall see you
know i've got a few more months of of
freedom so we're gonna try to enjoy it
as much as possible but i'm looking
forward to the next chapter um but it is
kind of funny the way
people respond when you tell them
because like we we're telling people and
everyone's like oh my god you know
you're gonna make a great dad and then
it's also like you better have fun now
this is it for you you had a hell of a
run 45 years you did it you did whatever
you wanted you were having fun all day
oh yeah drinking your tequila making
your steaks you think you can do
whatever you want you know
all right this is part of life it's part
of life and obviously there's a whole
bunch of goodness and stuff on the other
side